You got to admit, though, right? This a crazy thing to [music]
accuse somebody of. That's a crazy thing. I think you'd only
think this is a crazy thing to accuse somebody of if you're unfamiliar
with the slow descent into total insanity that Destiny's been
undergoing for the past 9 months, 10
>> We've got like the Hasan the 15-year-old drama going
on. These Hasan allegations are disgusting from Sensitive Society,
who's just hopping on this from the point of view of Destiny's
one statement. Very cool. >> wouldn't I actually I actually
just want to watch this, okay? Quick adjacent jump over to this
weirdo Sensitive Society. This guy always has the stupidest takes.
Let's see if he can top himself. >> be a sense Unfortunately,
not in the sense you're all hoping. Just top himself as in do
do even more disgusting [__] than he did the last
time. I don't mean top himself in the sense that you might be
hoping and thinking. Sensitive Society video, aka Sense, aka
Oscar. If we didn't talk about allegations, I swear to god this
happens on average at this point two to three times per month.
Now, before we really get into it, I just want to say these are
just allegations and pretty crazy allegations to throw out there.
Is this the 7-day watching Hasan guy? No, but I have heard that
that guy I think that guy's name is Conduit. I've heard that
he also released a new video and that new video
I spent 1 week watching Kyle Kulinski and it pushed me past my
breaking
I've heard that this video sucks and Hutch just watched it.
So, listen, we've always got that in the back pocket, okay? That
we've got this guy being terrible.
We've always got that. Big surprise, the
made another [__] video. Hey, I thought the Young
Turks video, it had some slight promise to it, okay? There were
some okay points in there. It wasn't the worst.
But realistically, the concerning thing about Conduit's videos
that I didn't really take into account at first was that his
videos are actually kind of like the tier of commentary I'd expect
from a live stream. Like I'm expecting this guy to have this
level of commentary on the
But it's in edited broken-down videos.
So, that's pretty bad when you think about it. Like you could
take all the time in the world to word yourself
And yeah, it just like kind of falls flat when like if it was
a live stream at that quality of um that's real really like almost
all I review is live stream stuff, right? And I didn't think
about it in terms of oh, this is like an edited video where this
guy had time to think about his messaging, think about things
he wanted to say, and he still kind of just like fell down pretty
hard. It's not great. It's not the best. All right.
Anyway, let's do the what? The Hasan allegations are disgusting
from Sensitive Society. about someone. I don't want to be sued.
So, we're going to treat this with respect, even though it's
Hasan and you guys know me, I don't like him, but even though
I don't like him and I will be the first one celebrating if he
got banned. Just because I don't like him doesn't mean I'm going
to be like, "Yeah, you know, he's guilty of doing it with the
15-year-old, but I don't want to get ahead of myself." Before
we get into it, please subscribe, drop a like. Hopefully, let's
see if we can reach 5,000 likes. Is that possible? Can can the
Sense army do it? So, this came out of nowhere. And when I mean
out of nowhere, I mean out of nowhere. Destiny claims Twitch
streamer Hasan effed Do you think this guy spent enough time
to go and see that Destiny has basically said multiple times
that he didn't think there's anything to this brothel drama?
Do you think he spent the time to go find that? That like you
would just see that Destiny's like clearly lying about it? That
he has said explicitly like let's not do this, let's not lie
about Hasan in the past?
No. No, okay. >> doesn't say boy or girl, so I don't think
it matters. I don't know why he said that. Hasan effed a 15-year-old
while on a trip in Berlin. In case you guys don't know, Destiny
is a pretty controversial YouTuber streamer. I'm not too familiar
with him. I don't really pay attention to the world of politics,
especially when it comes to I actually I actually believe personally
So, you think he's lying? Oh, he's absolutely lying. Uh he would
love nothing more than to get sued by Hasan and build content
off of that. He wouldn't care about the money. He would just
want the views from being a like against Hasan. That's how Destiny
like has always
fed his content, has always fed like his audience is he picks
the enemies that are the optimal enemies to have, right? So,
he Hasan's basically started ignoring him to a large extent.
He does not want that. He wants to be Hasan's number one enemy.
He doesn't want Hasan's number one enemy to be Asmongold or Asmongold's
community or Nick Fuentes or anybody else. He wants Hasan's number
one enemy to be Destiny. So, he's trying to get Hasan's attention
again and again and again because Destiny is a truly disgusting
individual himself and so the way he operates is by finding the
best enemies to have, the enemies that the most people hate so
that he can try to pretend to be the like mirror image of
That's what he thinks that's what he's trying to do here. He
wants the enemy that's every Hasan's like the internet's enemy
right now. Hasan is the guy that everybody hates. So, Destiny's
like, "Oh, if I can make Hasan freak out about me and sue me,
then I can get back on the other side of Hasan. I can get back
all of the people who hate Hasan on my audience or into my audience,
right?" Because he's a disgusting person who has no message of
his own. And when he had a message of his own, look at how his
community acted. When the when the allegations first came out,
they all went, "Oh, don't talk [__] about Pixie.
Don't like don't harass people who could be be victims. Hear
them out." And now it's like, "No, [__] this stupid
gold-digging her mind-controlling succubus Lauren Southern Laguna.
They they they make [__] about me. They've convinced
everybody around them to sue all the men around them, right?"
It's like it's totally different. Can we watch the recent Destiny
YouTube video on Hasan? I'm good. I'm good. But Red Pill one,
in this case hero is overdosing. Yeah, Destiny was red-pilled
from the very start, like obviously so.
Uh obviously in retrospect, not obviously back then. Obviously
so now. Twitch streamer's telling me the politics, I'm like,
"I'm good. I don't need Twitch streamers informing me on politics."
You might be wondering, "Is this even real? How did this This
guy says I'm good. I guarantee you this guy is totally politically
by the way. Sensitive Society, Destiny could be a and all of
the worst labels you could add on top of that, he could be all
of those things and he would know way more about you. Wait, sorry,
way more about politics than you do.
It's very obvious. Like I I and I straight-up despise this guy.
He is disgusting to me. But the idea that this guy's like, "I'm
good with the Twitch streamer commentary." No, you're not. You're
a almost certainly. even happen in the first place? Well, Destiny
has been a live streamer for a long time now. He is one of the
reasons why Hasan got popular in the first place. Destiny was
the first person to kind of push Hasan that wasn't his family.
Hasan started in the Destiny community, if I'm not mistaken.
Feel free to correct me if I'm ever wrong, but I'm pretty sure
that's a situation. And all of this started because Hasan said
There were numerous times when Ethan Klein wanted to actually
make fun of him for going on a date with a cat boy and [__]
like that back when we had the Left Overs podcast. I was like,
"Are you out of your mind? No, we're not covering him. It doesn't
matter. Even to ridicule him, we're not covering him at all.
We're not giving him any breathing room. We're not giving him
any platform whatsoever." And I actually vetoed that [__]
over and over again. They're [__] ideal that he paved
his own way? I mean, Hasan
is like somebody who probably would have had a career in media
no matter what.
People don't like to admit it. Honestly, most media at this point
is just being funny on a personal level in any given situation.
Like can you make people laugh? Can you make them forget about
their troubles? Even if you're just a even if you're a politician,
it's not really about policy in any way. It's about can you make
people laugh? Are you
You see that? There's no clearer example of that than Nick Fuentes,
right? Nick Fuentes' politics to most people are repugnant. Doesn't
matter. He's still going to be one of the most popular people
on the internet the second he's not deplatformed from everything.
So, Hasan probably would have been successful no matter what.
People can call him a nepo baby cuz he got his start with TYT
and Cenk, but I I still think he would have been popular no matter
what. ideological opponents who claim to be liberals may or may
not have sucked his and also
openly delivered them a fat platform and >> Oh, also I
think most of Hasan's politics are I'm just I'm just telling
you that like I think he probably would have been popular no
matter what. >> additional media connections and even
Nick Fuentes and even talked about how Nick Fuentes owed them
so much for their new career.
Yes, I'm talking about Destiny. Destiny says, "If Hasan is going
to reach you this hard to say that I kickstarted Fuentes' career,
then I am responsible for his career 10 times over. If you would
have left it at that, that would have been completely fine."
But then he continues, "Also, Hasan effed a 15-year-old when
he was visiting the brothel in Berlin. That's why he doesn't
like to talk about it as much now." Believe Hasan was in his
20s to mid-20s. If this is real, by the way. Once again, these
are insane allegations. Once again, I know it's Hasan and I know
that Hasan loves to call people
when there's next to no proof of them being a So, it's low-key
kind of hard for me to feel bad for him, but I don't want to
get sued. First thing that comes to mind is is there any proof
of this? Because if there isn't, then this is a crazy and insane
thing to lie about. And if Hasan sues Destiny for slander because
I mean that's what it is. I wouldn't be surprised. Uh Destiny
just always makes the mistake of
uh not Destiny even. Everybody makes the mistake of thinking,
"Oh, Destiny has like a reputation." He doesn't have he doesn't
think he has any reputation left. He can't evaluate like
He thinks he's constantly a rock bottom because he's in the worst
position he's been in in some like some interval in his life,
right? In the past like 3 years is maybe the worst position he's
been in in his life and so he thinks he can't go any lower. But,
he could.
He could. And truth be told, I wouldn't even be mad. This is
a crazy thing to drop on a [__] Monday afternoon.
Someone says, "That's quite the allegation." Which I totally
agree. Destiny responds with, "It's common knowledge behind the
scenes. If his son wants to contest it, he can sue me. But, he
won't because truth is an absolute defense." Has Destiny responded
to any of the commentary of him saying that this wasn't true,
that he didn't think this was a real thing, that he encouraged
Dan to stop pursuing it? Why did he encourage Dan to stop pursuing
it, right? If it was just not something that was known. It was
like something he thought was known.
It's against defamation. Now, I wish Destiny could show us a
little bit of proof because at that point I could just be like,
"Diesel patches and WestJet
me last night."
Hold on. I mean, could he could things get worse? Could things
get worse beyond getting outright banned? Yeah?
Yeah, his reputation could always be worse than it is now.
Yep. People pe- He's still got a ton of money, right? He's still
got a ton of money. He is
relatively like he's under 40, so he's not like old. He's not
got any major health conditions that we know of. Yeah, things
could always be worse.
Right? Dro- Dropping into like another lawsuit, if he did, while
it might reinvigorate some of his online platform,
I do think things could end up getting worse there. He told Lav
to chill out cuz none of it he knew none of it was true. Well,
he told Lav to chill out on the Paris Jackson and stuff. I don't
know about that. not the Paris Jackson allegation. It feel good
though? Some proof would be much appreciated, especially when
you're dropping a bombshell like, "Yeah, his son effed a 15-year-old
when he was in his 20s." Now, he does mention Berlin. I don't
know what the age of consent is in What is the age of consent
in Berlin? I'm curious. Not that that makes it okay, but I'm
just curious. So, the age of consent It's Yeah, it's under this.
>> in Berlin is 14. If I'm not mistaken, there's been multiple
times where his son calls Destiny a Uh if you're [__]
somebody in a brothel, the age of consent is 18.
No, if you're [__] somebody in a brothel, the age
of consent is 18.
Because the age of consent is 14 or 15 unless the person is being
coerced in some way. I'm guessing that prostitution would be
sex considered coercion. You definitely cannot a 15-year-old
in a brothel.
pedophile. Uh I wonder if this is to get back at him and if his
son sues him, then Destiny could be like, "Well, his son has
also called me a pedophile multiple times." And I don't know.
I know that Destiny has his own set of allegations to The commercial
age for prostitution in Germany is 18. But, the age of consent
is 14 or 15 so long as the person isn't coerced in any way. If
they are 14 or 15, they're coerced, which I would argue prostitution
almost certainly is. It's not like somebody just gets that in
their own mind, "Oh, I'm going to be a prostitute now at 14 or
15." Right? They're not even allowed to. They're actually doing
it illegally. Yeah, that's that's to me they're obviously being
coerced in some way. Or Sam, you're a No, you're a No, you're
more of a No, you are more. It's like, what? I don't I don't
know. I guess this is the battle of the As a matter of fact,
this is literally the meme that says two gay fighting. That's
literally it. This person says, "So, if we humor for a moment,
this means Destiny was sitting >> Yeah, at best at best
these Destiny allegations are like the Mischa thing. Right? Like
when Lav was saying Hassan people under age, Destiny was like,
"No, no, no, you can't say that. You can't say that. Don't say
that. Stop saying that. You're going to destroy Dude, that's
not a nuke. You can't say that." And then he knew about this
in the background? What?
That feels kind of weird. Why are you sweeping for this guy?
What? thing on proof that Hassan harmed a child and waited for
the exact moment to release it. I don't like Hassan, but if this
is untrue, I feel like Hassan should sue Destiny. I I agree.
And for >> Yeah, that's the thing, Kilo, is like
it is just obviously a lie, and it's a lie for the first thing
I said, right? It's an obvious lie because if he can position
himself as the counterpoint to
then he can start getting audience back, right? That's what he
wants to do. He wants to position himself as the counterpoint
to certain people. He's got a very dedicated small fan base who
are going to try to push him. What people need to do is they
need to start ignoring him because he is not doing things in
like good faith in an honest way. He is just lying and making
things up to try to get people's attention, to try to get the
right enemies so that he can present himself as, "Well, actually
like Yeah, I'm like a total I'm a total moral reprobate, but
like I'm against Hassan. I'm not Hassan. In fact, Hassan hates
me. Could I really be that bad if I'm like Hassan's enemy, if
I'm his like nemesis? Could I really be that bad?"
to side with Hassan, you know how insane or stupid you have to
be for me to be like, "You know, Hassan, if he's lying, you should
sue him. I I'm on your team now. I like you, Hassan. Can I please
come on stream?" And if it is true, that makes Destiny look horrendous
for withholding this information. I agree. This is similar to
when Mischa claimed that Emiru abused bunnies or whatever the
he was saying. This was what, 2 years ago? Now I feel Now I feel
scared about that take cuz this guy's going to copy that take,
and now I'm like, "Oh, [__] If this guy thinks the
same thing I thought, then I might be retarded." >> 3 years
ago, and he held to these videos of these bunnies once again,
quote unquote, being abused because their cages were nasty, yada
yada yada. It's like, "So, you knew, quote unquote, animal abuse
was taking place, but you didn't report it? You didn't talk about
it? You just held onto this to use it as blackmail one day?"
Once again, if we entertain the idea and we believe the the allegations,
it's like, "Oh, so Destiny knew Hassan effed a 15-year-old for
years and many other people behind the scenes." I'm trying to
see why he did this and why he said this in the first place.
There is no So, not only did he know that before this, apparently,
or something's changed
but he also defended Hassan from allegations on a different front
with the same thing in mind. So, he wanted to make sure that
people didn't think Hassan had a minor or that Hassan that anyone
was accusing Hassan of [__] a minor, while knowing,
apparently, that Hassan did [__] a minor. That's
like the universe we live in.
a win-win here. I mean, you either get sued or if this somehow
turns out Like if you knew somebody had murdered someone else,
but you for some reason couldn't reveal it, and then they were
accused of a different murder, and you're like, "No, no, no,
they'd never murder somebody. We have no evidence they're a murderer
at all." Wouldn't you feel like really weird saying that? Wouldn't
you kind of just shut the [__] up and not intervene
at all? Why the [__] would you intervene by going,
"No, no, no, they're not a murderer. Stop. Stop. You can't prove
they're a murderer. Stop." tell to be real. You knew he SA'd
a 15-year-old and you said nothing about it for years. It's not
a very good look for Destiny. I don't know. Maybe I just don't
see the vision. I guess only time will tell if
if he was telling the truth or he was >> The only the only
reason you'd ever believe this, by the way, this is just Destiny
doing creative writing again, just totally making something up
again, unless you can produce some kind of evidence. So, he just
He must have learned Listen, he he went he made all that [__]
up about being in Queman, and then he was like, "Wait, nobody
called me on that. I can just lie about whoever I want."
And then he made this up about Hassan. Or he'll post evidence
about it. I'm not sure which.
But, I I mean, I'm going to treat it like an obvious lie because
of everything this guy says and does until he proves it, right?
He's obviously shown that he can't be trusted with his his word
is trash. His word is garbage. He cannot be trusted at all.
And so, he has to prove it in some way. He has to give some kind
of proof. Or, you just hate Hassan enough that you're willing
to overlook all of the lies Destiny's done, all the things he's
made up without being able to prove it, to just go after Hassan.
Which I mean, that's a sad state of being. Good luck with that.
line. So, Destiny goes out and says this. This is all alleged.
I don't need another lawsuit, okay? This is the the main thing
is this, right? Destiny absolutely did help He did help Hassan
a lot whenever Hassan was first coming up, right? This is undeniable.
And then he said, "Also, Hassan effed a 15-year-old when he was
visiting that brothel in Berlin. That's why he doesn't like to
talk about it as much now." I I genuinely mean this. I think
Hassan should sue him if this isn't true. I do. I think Hassan
should sue him. Like this is a crazy accusation. Crazy, crazy,
crazy accusation to make at somebody. Yeah, wild. The other the
other funny thing here is that
like people people try to look at this and go, "Oh, well, Destiny
wouldn't do Bro, Destiny docks the person that he
to have it be revealed that he was [__] a minor.
That's who Destiny is. So, if you think, "Oh, he only acts like
logically, he only acts, you know, in a in a consistent, coherent
fashion." That's just wrong. That's provably
I still think that message is not out there for most people.
They don't realize Destiny docked a person who was a minor when
he was [__] with them. Or Apparently, he might even
try to cope and say, "Well, you with like their handler or something."
That doesn't make it better, bro. The the videos you were getting
were child porn. Regardless of if it was them sending you the
child porn or a a handler sending you the child
That's a crazy claim. Yeah, that's nuts. You can't just throw
that on on people >> And And he STILL DOCKED THE VICTIM
THERE. He still took the primary steps required to dock the victim
in all of that.
proof, man. Yeah, sure. And that's quite the allegation. It's
common knowledge behind the scenes. If Hassan wants to contest
it, he can sue me, but he won't because truth is an absolute
defense against defamation. I don't know. Like I even I almost
feel bad even giving this any attention at all because I feel
like maybe it's probably like I would never ever ever assume
this of somebody, right? I never would. I'll be curious to see
what his response is going to be if he even does respond. I mean,
it's just This is It's a I mean, I you got to admit though, right?
This a crazy thing to accuse somebody of. That's a crazy
I think you'd only think this is a crazy thing to accuse somebody
of if you're unfamiliar with the slow descent into total insanity
that Destiny's been undergoing for the past 9 months, 10 months,
right? You don't have to be completely ignorant of his like total
total loss of self-control, his total loss of ability to make
like coherent or intelligent decisions for himself or his platform,
right? You'd have to You'd have to have no understanding of this
to go and look at this statement and go, "Oh, yeah, that's probably
like he wouldn't say that if he was lying."
You You just have to be totally ignorant of all of it. Anyway,
Hasan the streamer who actively uses allegations he knows are
false as well as exaggerating the truth and accusing people of
things they never did. Now his child sex allegations that Destiny's
willing to go to court over. Brazy thing to say, "Yeah, this
guy effed a 15-year-old." But not show any receipts. There's
no proof. Anyone could legitimately be like, "Yeah, Sense touched
me back in 1998."
And I wasn't even born in 1998, but can anyone just say, "Yeah,
Sense did touch me when I was 5 years old." And they're from
[__] I don't know [__] is this guy talking
about right now? Jesus Christ. >> Switzerland. It's like
I've never been. Anyone could just say anything about anyone
and there's no repercussions, but it does taint your name. I
might not be the biggest Habibi [__] fan. I might
not even like the guy, right? I mean, the amount of people god,
is it possible that Destiny is so
his reputation is actually hold on. Wait, it might be possible
that Destiny's reputation is so that he can't make something
up like this about Hasan and people not have will not call him
out. Like people want to believe anything they can about Hasan.
Look at Tectone. Tectone immediately hopped on this. He was like
totally on the same page. But now this guy is pulling back. He's
like, "Ah, you know, I may not like Hasan, but this Destiny guy
is kind of making some [__] up. Like he shows any
proof, man? Come on." Well, that Habibi [__] has
slandered is pretty nuts. Cuz at this point what Destiny said
has gone kind of viral. And I'm assuming as time goes on only
more and more people are going to pick up on this. Let them fight.
Yeah, I'm just sitting here eating popcorn. I'm watching from
afar. I'm just reporting the news. We all know the sensitive
society is for the You're not reporting the news. Hold on. You're
not reporting the news.
>> You're not. I feel like what you should be doing here
is you should go, "There's literally no evidence of this. We
just have to withhold judgment."
Maybe Maybe that is the final message of his video, but it wasn't
the message at the start. whole family. When I say the whole
family, I mean the whole family. I got this DM a few hours ago
and it says, "I was watching your video this morning and my dog
went crazy when she saw ADP. It's like she knows."
Why are you barking at video games?
Like I'd understand if there were animals on the screen, but
there's not.
Shoutout to the person and shoutout to the dog. I'm telling you
the whole family watches Sensitive Society and even dogs are
I don't care. Okay. All right, there's one. I
Every time I see this guy's videos, I know they're rage bait
for me, okay? So
first thing I should say is guys, if you like the content, go
ahead follow on every platform. If you want to make the stream
go longer, you can sub, you can donate. Exclamation point donate
to get the TTS links. Subs, you know, Twitch primers, Kick subs,
all that stuff's good. I'm going to head over to Kick only for
the rest of the stream. We're going to move on to the Legal Mindset
video on this exact same drama. We'll check that out real quick.
All right, I'll be I'll be going over to Kick only, guys. It's
kick.com/jcsdlk.
If somebody can put that in the Twitch chat for me, kick.com/jcsdlk,
I appreciate that. All right, thank you very much. We're going
to head over to Kick only for the rest of the stream.
Bye-bye. Bye-bye, Twitchers. Bye-bye, my friends. Don't forget
to primer on your way out. Okay. So we shut off the Twitch stream.
We flip off multi-streaming.
Boom and we give it 2 seconds and then we're going to switch
over, guys. We're going to do the Legal Mindset video on the
same drama cuz apparently people got to follow on this drama.
in which you are specifically aware that establish, demonstrate,
or prove the allegation
Wait, what? >> including identity, location of each person
with It's my own [__] God damn. Oh god, Legal Mindset
uses it. You hear it? That was Legal Mindset. That's his [__]
Oh my goodness.
All right, let's get let's get into it. Legal Mindset video,
Destiny defames Hasan [__] fast facts
fast facts.
Let's see. Let's see if it's uh
I would say I would expect Legal Mindset to somehow be against
the uh like Hasan in all of
But again, I might be underestimating the reputational like
the nuclear waste dump that is Destiny's current reputation.
We'll see. Give me 2 seconds also. I'll be right back here at
the bottom of the >> now We'll let uh We'll let Andrew
Cook for just a second. I'll be right back. >> defamed
Hasan [__] in a leftist on a socialist battle. Uh
we're going to get into that today on Legal Mindset where I teach
you to be your own judge cuz I'm Andrew Esquire, American attorney,
enjoying my time here in the USA for however long that is, keeping
that a little mysterious as I get into this creator drama and
this potential legal issue for Destiny who's already embroiled
in deep allegations regarding his past conduct, which is the
course of a current lawsuit including potential possession of
CSAM on his computer. Uh and in an attempt to perhaps deflect
from this is attempting to defame Mr. Hasan [__]
who is once again and not doing well on the internet either and
is certainly subject to many of his own scrutinies coming from
Corgate to various other comments he's made and defamation of
his own and other behaviors. So it's kind of the bad against
the bad here of which I have no particular dog in this fight
whether Hasan or Destiny prevails against each other. That is
something I do not care about, but it brings up some fascinating
legal questions and even some international legal questions as
we get into today on the Legal Mindset. Of course, I've got the
PowerPoint for you. I've got the PP and we're going to talk about
that today here with Destiny defaming Hasan. So let's get into
it. Obviously our players What an awesome intro. I love this
Legal Mindset guy. are our characters in this you know drama
today. This legal drama today is Destiny. You know, once again,
I love this Attack on Titan version of him.
It's just absolutely my favorite. You got Destiny obviously a
streamer and Now question for you guys. Is this the Photoshop
version or
I actually don't know if this is the Photoshop version or not.
Like is his head made bigger intentionally in this one? Cuz I
know there's like a Instagram account that made his head bigger
in all the pictures so you couldn't really tell it's real. It's
a real version. Okay. All Obviously a once again well-known on
the left and I think this is very critical in terms of their
political position because they're both jockeying for supporters
within their own area. And that's relevant to one of the reasons
that might be behind this is obviously people on the left are
I don't think this guy understands that these audiences couldn't
be more like diametrically opposed to one another. Like there's
not somebody in Destiny's audience who's like a big fan who's
switching over to Hasan's audience or vice versa. It's like a
really bad analysis right off the bat. >> are all fighting
with other people on the left for their supporters, for people
to follow them because people on the right are not going to go
and jump over and watch Destiny or Hasan. But people on the left
could be persuaded to >> I legitimately think there's far
more reason for a right-winger to watch Hasan or watch Destiny
than there is for a DGGer to watch some HasanAbi head some some
Hasan content or a HasanAbi head to watch Destiny.
I feel like he doesn't understand this is like the Capulets and
Montagues, okay? They're going to the more radical end, you might
say, with uh with Hasan or the more unhinged end with Destiny.
Kind of pick your character there with either one. Uh but now
with Hasan, uh who's the other character here and of course you've
got his constant uh protector and uh senpai there, Dan Clancy.
Um Hasan once again, not no innocent angel over here. Hasan definitely
has many flaws of his own, but even a flawed person can be defamed.
Even a flawed person or a person that we don't like can still
end up being defamed. And as we do it on this channel, I'm going
to be very obvious and up front and honest with you guys about
this legal analysis in which I
looking at it, it doesn't look good for Destiny. It looks much
better for Hasan [__] So this involves the Artemis
Brothel in Germany. Now one important thing Oh.
OH MY GOD. WAIT, is Legal Mindset There's no way
that Legal Mindset
it looks better for Hasan? Wait, he goes into the Artemis Brothel?
Is he actually going to go through the allegations?
The actual investigation that happened, what the what the findings
of fact were? There's no way. And this is something that's very
critical and a lot of people lose this, particularly if you don't
travel outside of the United States, is that the uh the engagement
of sex work around the world is not like it is in the United
States. In some countries, it's legalized formally.
In some countries, it's legalized informally. In some countries,
the definition of prostitution is something that is very narrow.
So because of that narrow definition, it's kind of informally
uh it's informally okay even though on the books it's not okay.
But in Germany, they've formally done it and in fact as part
of that, much like the Netherlands and other countries, they
said, "Hey, you've got to do things like provide, you know, benefits
for these people. You've got to pay for them. They've got to
get wages." You know, the sort of protections that you'd want
if you're going to >> I mean, the biggest one would be
the documentation. We need to know who they >> decriminalize
sex work, you're going to legalize sex work, and to make it safe
for the people involved. And one of the people who's actually
been surprisingly pro
sex work legalization is Hasan [__] Now why I say
surprisingly because his typical leftist allies are typically
against that. In fact, the groups that are most rabidly against
that are usually radical feminist groups, although there are
What? Like the Is he saying like the sex positivity movement,
the female empowerment movements have been anti-prostitution.
Okay. Groups on the right that are opposed this as well, but
once again, we're talking about inter-left
battle here. So, looking at this mega brothel, once again, uh
Some Some could be. But on balance, trying to be trying to say
anti-prostitution,
the position of of being against prostitution is a leftist position,
that's that's insane. That's an insane thing to say. It's not
cited? No, it is cited. It's absolutely cited. That work is a
conservative position.
By and large, trying to pretend that a tiny cohort on the left
that is against work represents the same thing as almost the
entire conservative movement being against work, that's insane.
That's an insane thing to say. It's not cited. It is obviously
cited as in conservatives oppose sex work.
Hasan literally dated a porn star. To To the idea that he would
be against work or his followers would be against sex work is
insane.
a place that was established during FIFA because the owner, as
he quoted during the World Cup, uh and football uh belong together.
So, he uh started this mega brothel, and it's been in operation
for a while.
But uh Destiny came out and said uh if Hasan is going to reach
so hard, and once again, uh I'll I'll give some context here.
Destiny is mad because of Hasan's jokes about Nick Fuentes and
him engaging in a potential amorous relationship. What Once again,
whether or not these things are true, who knows, right? Maybe
Destiny wants to come after Hasan for defamation in regards to
his relationship with Nick Fuentes. That would be a fun case
to cover. Uh but beyond that, uh Destiny was fun was was
What What is happening? >> a potential here. Then I am
responsible for his career Hasan's career 10x0. >> Sorry.
Sorry. And said uh if Hasan is going to reach so hard, and once
again, uh I'll I'll give some context here. Destiny is mad because
of Hasan's jokes This is literally not even remotely an answer
to my question.
That's not relevant at all. about Nick Fuentes and him engaging
in a potential amorous relationship. What Once again, whether
or not these things are true, who knows, right? Maybe Destiny
wants to come after Hasan for defamation in regards to his relationship
with Nick Fuentes. That would be a fun case to cover. Uh but
beyond that, uh Destiny was fun was was Destiny was mad about
this joke, this fun that was made at his expense. And Uh so,
he clapped back at Hasan. And he said Hasan is going to reach
this hard to say I kick-started Fuentes' career.
Then I am responsible for his career Hasan's career 10x0. And
once again, nothing about that first part is necessarily defamatory.
They're arguing about whether or not they got Fuentes a start.
Who knows about that? That's really neither here nor there. But
the second part is the defamatory part. Uh and that is Hasan
effed a 15-year-old when he was visiting that brothel in Berlin.
That's why he doesn't like to talk about it as much now. And
he continued Destiny doubled down on this. And this is the part
where it really gets into defamation uh saying that's quite the
allegation. And Destiny says it's common knowledge behind this
common knowledge without providing any sort of proof without
I Can I get one other person to step out under this ledge with
Destiny? In fact, why doesn't Dan Saltman step out on this ledge?
Why doesn't Dan Saltman step out here and say, "I know for a
fact that Hasan fight the Hasan [__] 15-year-old."
Why won't Dan Dan hates Hasan. Can we get Dan Saltman on this
one? Dan.
Please, Dan. Go ahead and step out on this on this plank with
Destiny and say, "Yeah, I know for a fact Hasan [__]
Go ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead. Without providing any sort of car
facts, without putting any sort of other thing saying, "Hey,
Hasan told me this himself. If Hasan wants to contest it, he
can sue me, but he won't because the truth is an absolute defense
against defamation." Well, I hope you have a Wait. Where did
he read in that Wait, what? knowledge without providing any Hasan
told me this himself without behind any sort of car facts, without
putting any sort of other thing saying, "Hey, Hasan told me this
himself."
Okay, without producing any sort of facts or hard facts or that
Hasan told him this himself.
I mean, even if he said Hasan told him it himself with there's
no hard facts,
I I think he should um He should say that, right? He should say
Hasan told me this or something, and then it could just be a
he said she said. But he's saying it's common knowledge behind
the scenes. Uh if Hasan wants to contest it, he can sue me, but
he won't because the truth is an absolute defense against defamation.
Well, I hope you No. No. Major Dr. Gasly, Dan is very careful
about not getting sued, right? Dan goes and says
uh what do you call it? Dan goes and says, "No, all I know is
they were raided, and there was a 15-year-old working at the
brothel."
Right? Like somewhere around that time when they were raided
They were raided because there was like a 15-year-old who was
trafficked by some pimp, and he provided papers that made it
seem like they were an 18-year-old.
Right? Although curiously enough, that would be the exact same
predicament Destiny was in, right? Destiny would have no judgment
for Hasan because Hasan is at a brothel, he's going to assume
that people are over 18 there because it's that's the legal requirement,
right? you have a lot of proof of that because just saying it's
common knowledge Oh, it was 17, by the way, and also not publicly
confirmed. Okay, >> doesn't actually do that. And what
I think he means by common knowledge is it's on internet forums.
It's on places that perhaps don't like Hasan, right? And put
that line out there. So, let's look at the actual facts here.
So, the facts of that about Artemis, when you look it up online,
and you look into, "Okay, what actually happened with this brothel?"
What you really find is Dude, is this going to cause The real
question is, is this going to cause tension between LegalMindset
and Techtone? Cuz Techtone loves to talk about this. And LegalMindset's
going to kind of dispel some of Techtone's favorite talking points
about Hasan
While kind of pseudo-defending Hasan. Is there going to be a
rift between Techtone and LegalMindset now? Cuz Techtone loves
to call Hasan. He loves loves to point out that Hasan went to
a brothel that had underage people at it. What honestly is a
tax raid. And as we all know, the Joker even fears the taxman.
You do not mess with the taxman. You make sure you pay your taxes.
Guys, pay your taxes, right? Um there was a massive raid on a
German mega brothel. This is in 2016. So, uh remember, uh this
is after Hasan visited. But there's a uh alleged human trafficking
and tax fraud. And this was a raid in 2016 where they were accused
of evading 17.5
million in social security payments. Now, this is uh something
that is very common not just with brothels, but with many companies
where they make people pretend to be self-employed to avoid these
payments for social security. I'm looking at you, Nijisanji VTuber
companies. They do this all the time uh with, you know, pretending
people are self-employed when really they're making them work
like employees. So, they were conducting this with customs officials
and tax fraud in in investigators. And generally what was found
after that, and there were several appeals and challenges here,
but generally was that they were not paying their taxes properly.
And that is very much on the nose with this. Once again, after
Hasan was there. I doubt that Hasan has the capability or qualities
to do German accounting and be liable for their social security
payments. But uh the fact is is that he did visit Ar- Artemis
in 20 uh 10. And now, Hasan does openly support decriminalization
of sex work, which of all the positions out there, that's probably
one that I agree with Hasan more than anything else, which is
kind of crazy.
Yeah. Yeah, that's why I That's why I went east. That's why I
went east. It's all legal sex work out there, guys. >> Because
that that issue kind of splits along the male-female divide.
Typically, most men across divides typically would agree with
that. I don't think so. I don't think that's true. Why is Does
he know anything about politics?
The average conservative in America does not think sex work should
be legalized if they're a man.
What the [__] are you talking about? Some females
agree with that, some don't. It's kind of split there, but that's
a very interesting one as a lot of the the stiff opponents are
the radical leftists. Uh we don't know the age of the gender
of any sex worker engaged by uh [__] Now, I'll talk
about that later because you can't This is also kind of goofy
that he says age of consent in Germany is 14, but the legal age
to work in a brothel is 18.
And the entire purpose of having legalized brothels is that they
can check people's paperwork and confirm that they're 18. So,
you don't have to do that. >> make an accurate statement
about [__] and you can say things about his visit
that are non-defamatory.
Uh the other thing is the age of consent in Germany is 14. So,
if he did engage a 15-year-old sex worker, it would not necessarily
be illegal. Now, I don't know all the German He's wrong. He's
just again
Oh, it's just totally classic
garbage again and again and again and again. Literally just
What is the legal age to engage in
in Germany? To engage in prostitution,
to What is the legal age to become a prostitute, let's say? To
become a
in Germany?
Oh, 18 years. Oh, 8
Oh, 18 years. Wow, that was so hard. That's like a question that
nobody would ask when making this video, isn't it? That's like
a totally unthinkable question. What age is legal to engage in
sex work in Germany? That's totally not a question you should
ask when you make this video. Wow.
Even when I want LegalMindset to succeed, he just he finds a
way to lower the bar for me. It's so crazy. statutes on sex work,
it's possible that while the age of consent in Germany is 14,
there could be some statute regulating German sex workers, right?
>> Hold on. Hold on. Sofia, why did you say this? There's
not something in the law that says unless she was pregnant, right?
So, Sorry, you said unless she was is
Please tell me that was in response to something else. Reread
it. Unless she is pregnant. Reread it. There's no way that does
that didn't say it. Uh, the stripper must be at least 18 years
of age. The registration certificate may not be issued if the
person is expected an expected mother in the last 6 weeks before
delivery at the time of registration. You must have attended
a counseling session at the Berlin Center for Health Counseling
in accordance with
So, so hold on. At you can't you it's 18 unless you're pregnant
and then this and then you can't. I thought you were saying like
if they were pregnant at 16 they could suddenly become a prostitute.
I was like like oh they're they're a mom they're going to need
the money. I thought that's what you were saying. I was I got
like by that comment. That says they need to be 18 or they need
to be 16 or whatever else. I don't know that. I'm not a German
work expert. By the way, if there's some German work experts
out there, please throw us please throw a comment below. Uh,
and like the video by the way. You should like the video whether
you're a German industry expert or not. Um, and we so we know
that. So, technically This is this is literally the
This is literally the first Google search. Even what he said
about Hassan wouldn't be accusing him of a crime. Now, it would
be accusing him of something that would be damning to Oh, I don't
know if the crime is on behalf of the brothel or Hassan. Like
I don't know how that would be applied necessarily. My thoughts
are that the age of consent is 14 unless you're coerced into
this by somebody older. If the person who is older coerces you
into this somehow as in if they're like a teacher or they have
some position of power over you, then that is still a crime.
Now, if they're a customer you've been like forced into this
trade, I do believe there should be some culpability on the behalf
on behalf of other people. I just don't know if it'd be the customers.
I'm not 100% sure. >> to his reputation. It would probably
depend on how how reasonable how reasonable it would be to think
that the person was underage despite the fact that you're at
a legal brothel where they're supposed to check people's papers
and [__] That's very true. Especially if he's trying
to imply that this was you know in in somebody that was hired
illegally or there's something illegal going on or being trafficked
[laughter]
I do like this last I do like this last bullet point though.
Destiny admitted to see on his PC. Yep. Yep. The other thing
we do know, and this is once again I think very relevant to this,
is that Destiny admitted to see Sam on his PC. He's essentially
said he was lying.
>> illegally blacked the as as Mr. Legal Mindset pointed
out, it was related to not paying out social security or not
making social security contributions. I would assume on behalf
of the prostitutes. the as etc. on his PC about Rose, you know,
who was at the time and based on all the facts we know right
now was underage, right? Which fits the criteria for that. So,
obviously there's some deflection that needs to happen on or
that Destiny is trying to make happen on his part. So, an analysis
of the truthful statement a truthful statement that is non-defamatory
would say that Hassan visited a German mega brothel that was
later raided for tax fraud and human trafficking. You can say
it was raided for that, right? That's true. There appeals or
other things that happened there, right? And now there's a lot
of talk about the underage person etc. What what all the underage
claim I didn't think about this. This should have been the most
predictable take, okay? Cuz I guarantee you Legal Mindset's gone
to some Thai brothel somewhere, some Thai brothel, some Filipino
brothel and gone yeah, this girl's 18, right? And they're like
yes, wink. Yes, wink. 18, yes, wink. Right? And he's like dude,
they said they said she was 18. Hassan had no way of knowing.
Of course he had no way of knowing. Apparently
that happened in 2013 and was unrelated to operations in 2010.
I'm not sure it's the details on that are very sparse. It's hard
to find exactly what happened in 2013. It might have been related
to somebody who was working there but did it outside of business
or regular operations. But as far as I know, this place is still
operating and based on its continued operation, you would assume
that regular operations do not engage people that are under Germany's
age consent. So, that would be a assumption and that's important
for defamation because if he's trying to accuse that hey, this
person engaged in This 2016 is not hard to find. Oh jeez.
Okay, when did Hassan go? Didn't Hassan go in like 2009?
Am I crazy for thinking Hassan went like way earlier than people
think?
2010, yeah, 2010. Okay, so he went in 2010. So, so if the underage
claim came from 2016, it's almost for sure that Hassan wouldn't
have [__] that underage person, right? Right? something
underage, well, it would appear that that was not the case in
2010 and therefore the most you could say, and I think this is
fair, is that if Hassan visited Artemis in 2010, he likely engaged
a sex worker, right? Likely. That you can't say for sure cuz
you don't know. Now, what >> Dude, this guy has never been
more
I'm I promise you
Legal Mindset is just defending himself in his own mind, right?
That's all he's doing. He's just defending himself in his own
brain. Yeah, Hassan has become him. He's just like running his
own defense that he's he's gone through this defense, this case
in his own mind like a thousand different times and he is just
running the entire ring. He's running the ringer through that
to defend Hassan right now. But he he sees himself and not Hassan.
That's why he's able to defend Hassan kind of
somewhat effectively somewhat effectively. He's obviously still
lazy and doesn't bother putting any work into But he's able to
defend Hassan a little bit. Destiny is implying is that he was
sitting in the chair in the corner. Now, while Destiny is very
used to sitting in the chair in the corner while other people
enjoy women behind him, I don't think he was in there in the
room with Hassan. Hassan can testify to that himself. Unless
Destiny was in the room watching him, I don't think there is
any proof of that that Destiny could possibly muster that would
meet an appropriate bar that would get him scot-free off of defamation
at a motion to dismiss level. Remember guys, and we've talked
about this with many cases. It's not I think this case could
be winnable by Hassan. It's just that
Hassan might realize that Destiny's just looking for any engagement
he can get at
And that like this is the one way Destiny's trying to reset the
This is one of the ways Destiny's trying to reset his reputation
in some way. Just ignoring him. Calling him like a total re might
be a better choice, right?
But like it it is a per se thing, no? Maybe not. Maybe you could
accuse him of [__] 15-year-old. Maybe you think that's
that's legal somehow.
You aren't accusing him of a crime. about winning the whole case.
It's about getting past the motion to dismiss, getting to discovery,
and then getting him to settle. And I think Destiny will be forced
to settle on this because I don't think he's got enough bulletproof
evidence to get that motion to dismiss and say yep, truth is
absolute defense and I've got the truth. I know the truth. Were
you in the room, Destiny? Were you sitting in the chair in the
corner? I mean, if you were, I think that's the story of the
century, but I don't think that was the case here. So, my conclusion
is Hassan has a solid case for defamation against Steven Bonnell
and that's of course Destiny. Destiny is likely deflecting from
his own issues and Hassan is a very easy target particularly
after Colargate. Bro,
the the actual conclusion
is accurate, right?
The actual conclusion is accurate. That's crazy.
This might be the first time I've come to the end of a Legal
Mindset video and like wait, that conclusion is actually probably
true. Now,
I but the thing he didn't talk about here which is a little confusing
cuz I don't think Destiny's necessarily accusing him of a crime.
So, it wouldn't be per se it would be actual malice would be
the standard, right?
That's a tricky thing even with Hassan's
Or sorry, even with Destiny's previous statements not Hassan's.
Even with Destiny's previous statements, I think the actual malice
standard is like nearly impossible. But Destiny has like defended
Hassan on this exact issue like kind of multiple times.
Oh, you have no evidence that Hassan's minors. You have no evidence
he's ever done that. Oh, actually actually pretending that Hassan
somebody at these brothels is insane. That's totally insane.
No, be better than that, guys. Be better than that. Right? Remember
the Simply Substance
Let's see if Substance if that clip's still here. Let me check
out Substance's
Real quick. Doesn't have to be a crime for it to be per se. I
thought it had to be a crime for it to be Wait, hold on. Why
isn't Substance popping up? Oh, I just didn't have the right
name. I got
Here, hold on. We'll just watch the video. Now,
technically there's some way to get around this, isn't there?
Hassan raped a girl at a brothel This is this is Destiny in January
or something. Hassan raped a girl at a brothel
that was trafficking trafficking trafficking minors, but somehow
Destiny's the worst person Tom ever associated with can't make
this right. So, I don't think Hassan raped anybody. I don't think
that's true. We don't have to do that. We don't have to sink
to that here.
>> more interested in political stuff than just hanging
with people, but
if you're going to support me, support me by supporting what
we do best, not by becoming the worst of the worst. Which is
every
I'm just I'm just hardcore doxing anyone I can find information
on now. Yeah.
Like I don't know how that fall off doesn't shock people. He
was like trying to be a good person. He like he wore this weird
like mask. Doesn't this mask concern you more than anything else
about this guy?
Right? Like the fact that he can go from oh guys, we're going
to be good. We're like the good people. And and then he just
totally drops it. He's like slightly inconvenienced. He just
totally drops the mask entirely. every other >> It's crazy.
Now, the only thing I would say about the actual malice standard
here is he says oh, Hassan didn't rape anybody. Technically you
could maybe get out of calling this rape in Germany in some way.
Maybe he's like trying to lean on that. Oh, my understanding
was I wasn't accusing him of a crime. I don't
But it seems to me
if you're talking to somebody Americans, you're talking to a
mostly American audience, they think 15-year-old is a 25-year-old,
28-year-old, 29-year-old is rape statutory rape, right? So, to
me he's saying no no no, Hassan didn't a minor at this brothel.
That didn't happen. Don't say that. Don't lie about it. Right?
Seems pretty obvious to me that's this is the common sense that
would, you know, apply here.
Seems like a brothel. Anyway. Anyway,
let's let's >> Colgate not going anywhere anytime soon.
And Hasan is seen as a low-hanging fruit that everyone can just
kick. But despite
it says Destiny is an app Uh that's what I said to keep the sunset,
but that sounds that honestly sounds like what Destiny would
actually believe, so.
Your your comment got deleted from Kick by the AI mod. Oh, let
me throw it up on screen. Okay, but then Destiny would be claiming
that 15-year-old in your mid-20s isn't Yes, I believe Destiny
fully believes that. I believe there's tons of evidence that
Destiny believes that. He's 100% on that page. Right?
Yeah, I just I don't think there's any question that Destiny
truly believes that in his heart of hearts that a 15-year-old
and a 25-year-old wouldn't be right. Target. He has the funds
for defamation. He's somebody you might want to go at. Typically
with defamation, you don't want to go at it with small fry with
losers with people that are below you. But these guys are the
same level, they're rivals. This would be a very appropriate
case. Why Where are they rivals? Where are they at the same
I don't think there's any argument for that at all.
Not at all.
Uh someone on Twitter unironically made that argument.
Destiny didn't say said Hasan did not grape the girl, not that
he did not kid. Yeah.